[Musique]
enfin les enfants petit patron c'est
aujourd'hui ma feuille non ce n'est pas
vrai nounours ce n'est pas ta fête
aujourd'hui ses pour uire prêteront je
vais faire la même charge un nicolas et
à patronale or ils vont être bien
attrapé mon échelle et repentant bon
pour bobos le luron le bonsoir petit ami
c'est aujourd'hui ma femme
cette affaire oui nicolas assieds toi ne
nous nous revenons tout de suite du don
vous ne me faites pas une farce pour ma
peur aux eaux ne bouge pas comme ça
écoute
vasily kona je goûte on voit là un je
veux j'ai vu quand pk tu vu j'ai vu une
grenouille qui filait sa quenouille au
bord d'un fossé au jeu j'ai vu qu'on
paie cas tu vu
j'ai vu une mouche sera c'est la bouche
avec un pavé à j'ai vu j'ai vu qu'au
père cac et vie j'ai vu une entité qui
coiffe et sa fille au tac le che quand
on m'a dit oh merci les enfants c'est
flou ce propos ce n'était peut-être pas
ma faute mais ce n'était pas tout à fait
oui ou non non non et non je crois que
c'était ma peur oui c'est ça ou les je
ne sais plus quoi fin oui eh bien moi je
sais ce que tu vas faire tu vas vite au
lit gros farceur et importe des fleurs
est parfaite
merci
pour lui le jeune femme fait des bannis
[Musique]
m
et
le
à te voilà
gro farseth aux patrons je voulais leur
faire une blague
ils ont été tellement gentil avec moi
olol l'eau tu vois quoi ça mène de dire
des choses qui ne sont pas vraies mais
ne t'inquiète pas nos deux petits amis
sont tellement gentils qui t'ont déjà
pardonné au maire patron
peut-être bien couché dôme a fait au nom
ne recommence plus gros qu'aucun au
coucou allons en route
bonne nuit les enfants
faites pourraient pas de nuit
e
[Musique]
à